all right this is from business uh
insider it says a mcdonald's in medford
oregon has a banner out front
advertising that it's hiring 14 and 15
year old workers
the biddle road restaurant operator
heather coleman told insider they're
always staffing issues but this is
unheard of she said the situation is
unique in her family's 40-year history
operating mcdonald's franchises
the young workers have been a blessing
in disguise coleman said
they have the drive and work ethic
they get the technology they catch on
really quickly she says
while raising the minimum wage to 15
didn't bring in as many applicants as
she'd hoped opening the doors to 14 and
15 year olds brought in about 25 new
applications in two weeks she said
uh well what do you know we were told
it's the it's got to be 15 an hour
that's supposedly a living wage
because apparently someone is working
part-time running a cash register at
mcdonald's that's supposed to be a job
like a career that you can live off of
and they raise the minimum to uh they
raise the they do the 15
minimum wage and has no effect
people still aren't interested
um instead no wha why are they
attracting 14 and 15 year olds one of
the reasons is that 14 and 15 year olds
aren't getting that sweet unemployment
money from from the uh from the
government
and they weren't directly receiving the
stimulus checks
but for whatever reason and i say that
kind of rhetorically i know the reason
uh the reaction to this and there are
other the article goes on this is a
trend now as more and more fast food
restaurants especially are directly
advertising themselves to 14 and 15 year
olds putting banners out front saying 14
to 15 year olds we're hiring come on in
and this has been
apparently for some people controversial
they're kind of upset about this
i mean how dare you
try try to advertise to the sweet
innocent children
they should all be sitting at home on
their phones that's what they should be
doing as children
i don't see why is this controversial i
don't see why this should be
controversial
i had my first job my first i had my
first official job
working at uh it was a snowball stand
and i think i was making like
four and a half dollars an hour or
something
i had that job when i was 13.
and i had unofficial under the table
jobs mowing lawns before that probably
like from the age of 11 i had some kind
of paying job
certainly by 14 and 15 definitely
so
not only is it okay for mcdonald's and
fast food restaurants to advertise to 14
and 15 year olds it's a good thing they
should be doing this
for for two reasons number one
it's good for the kids
what's the downside they're not they're
not working in a coal mine we're not
sending them down to the coal mines not
they're not working
you know in
in a factory in the early period of the
industrial age
where factory accidents are happening
seven times a day and their you know
arms are getting caught in machines and
ripped off that's they're sitting there
running a cash register pouring some
salt onto fries and that's it maybe they
get a little if there's some splash from
the grease they get a little bit burned
i think they'll be okay
so it's good for the kids it's not bad
for them it's good for them they're
learning learning work ethic they're
earning a little bit of their own money
uh i i could tell you for sure that as a
kid and this is there's no contest here
at all for me personally i went to
public school and i also had part-time
jobs and uh where did i learn the most
in the jobs for sure
that was the best education
so you're learning not only generalized
sort of work ethic and
how to show up on time how to fulfill
your responsibilities those are really
important lessons for kids to learn and
other lessons and also lessons that they
often don't learn in the public school
system
but they're also just some basic
skills that you're learning
running a cash register you got to do
math at least back in those days there
was some math involved at least now it's
all now not quite as much
but um still you're kind of you're
you're applying some of the academic
things that you're learning in school in
the real world and so it's all positive
it's a great thing
it's also good for families
especially lower income families i mean
because we have this idea
that kids like you shouldn't get a job
until you're 18 or something and even
then maybe don't get a job
and so in lower income families and
really in any family
you have kids who are able-bodied they
could easily get a part-time job and do
it
and contribute to the household income
at least be able to buy some things for
themselves
be contributing members of the family
and uh but but so often they're not
because of this absurd idea that some
people have
that it's it's wrong for a teenager to
work
and then the other point also is that
these jobs are are made for teenagers
that's why the raise the minimum wage
thing
the vast majority of people aren't even
aren't on minimum wage
um that's a that's a that's a relatively
small minority of the overall working
population
and a great number of them are young and
these are jobs that are not meant to be
it's like these are not a minimum wage
job is not meant for
someone like myself 35 years old with
four kids at home
because even if they raise the minimum
wage
to 15 an hour that's still not really
going to be enough to fulfill all the
obligations that i have
these jobs are made for kids it's
perfect for them
because they they don't have they don't
have a family to support on their own
they don't have kids of their own
hopefully
uh they can do these kind of minimal
tasks
that are very easy to learn
and benefit in the process it's a great
thing it's a wonderful thing
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated